like are you following what's going on
with Jamie Foxx he's not feeling well
there's something's going on with him
yeah they said stroke I had no idea what
happened to him yeah can you pull that
up
we were at a restaurant a couple months
ago in L.A and what was the restaurant
the steak uh remember the restaurant in
L.A anyway
yes yes and he showed up and looked
really good and then all of a sudden you
hear the stories about
uh uh Jamie Foxx was a Chicago rail
facility Hey listen we can't anticipate
that neck breath we don't know when
we're gonna die
after we leave this bad stuff can happen
is he still doing the the movie or no is
he still uh because what wasn't there
like stories of him playing your life
well it was a possibility you know I
don't know what's gonna happen now but
you know it's a strong possibility yeah
he uh uh uh because you know Jamie's
closer to my age so in order to do him
they were going to do what they did with
um Benjamin Button you remember yeah
make him look younger type of deal yeah
I mean they know how to do that
absolutely has there any been any actual
news uh news on what this medical
condition is I mean Jimmy Fox is a young
vibrant healthy guy
Hey listen um if we don't know by now
they don't want us then yeah
you know what time come on man stop I
gotta wake up question so if you like
this clip and you want to watch another
one click right here and if you want to
watch the entire podcast click right
here
[Music]